my name is fairy Argyle rainbow and I am
the original designer of the first set
of rainbow flags and this is that story
when I was in junior high and high
school I was interested in clothing and
I knew how to sew and so I wanted
colorful I wanted to paint stuff and
diet learn how to die so I got some
bottles dye and I read the instructions
but it didn't come out how I wanted so I
read up some more stuff and then it was
like oh maybe if I tried that
it'll get brighter or maybe it'll work
better if I heat it up and it was just
like trial and error Edgar Cayce was one
of the people I was interested in and he
had this whole thing about healing with
colors and he was a psychic medium and
he wrote books about healing with colors
and I read all that and I was like oh
boy you know I love colors and and they
could you know maybe they're influential
and your health so I've got an art
school scholarship to the Academy of Art
in the summer when I was 17 to San
Francisco and that's where I met other
people in the theater and the arts when
I moved to San Francisco I supported
myself with dyeing and sewing making
clothes and dance costumes and costumes
and people's special boutiques and a
special clothing designer where I did
all her fabrics I got hooked up with
these children's theatre company called
the moment Museum and I met a woman
named Bethany the princess of our gala
she did shows for kids children's live
performances and she said oh I don't
like the name Lynne I like the name
fairy you know I'm gonna name you fairy
cuz you're like fairies in the forest
the helpers the little fairies our gal
would be my middle name because she was
the princess of Aragon I was in that
theater company and then rainbow because
of loving Rainbow I got involved with
the Angels of Light Theatre Company of
San Francisco so I got involved at the
gay community center cuz it was right by
one of the Angels of Light House and we
used to walk everywhere and so and then
Lee mentally was the art
gallery curator at the community center
on the top floor gallery and we already
knew him from the children's theater and
so we all came together and he said why
don't you rent we'll rent you a room on
the second floor of the gay community
center you can do your dying there
here's the room it had a stove it had
running water but no hot water but we
used to just heat it up in canning pots
and then I'd mix in giant trash cans in
that room with that had a large table
too and make a big mess and then I had
to run off to the wash mat laundromat to
wash everything they were making
arrangements to put the parade on you
know I think it was probably leave asked
me do I want to be part of the
decorations committee because I'm right
there every day so yeah of course
Gilbert came along he he came along
during this period but there was another
a third person that's got no credit and
he passed away from AIDS his name's
James McNamara and he's the guy that
taught Gilbert how to so he went to fi t
he knew how to so beautifully in pattern
he made his own clothing line and he was
a mentor to me we had a little meeting
of three people to decide what the
decorations would be so I had some
sketches or something and this idea of
making rainbow flags because at the time
I was very Argyle rainbow and I did a
lot of rainbows and that was really my
thing
so everybody loved it you know and I
also knew how to make flags I had
already made flags for a sailboat
company they said oh we'll give you the
reflecting pool had rows of flag poles
along it at the city hall and then
they'll give you these two big flag
poles at UN Plaza so we need two big
ones and then we need these smaller ones
and they were gonna be each individual
artist like you get a flag you get a
flag you get a flag here's your white
flag we've stitched them up and now it's
up to you to color this however you want
is your project we need them back by
this time and then the two big flag
poles were like James and I were like
okay
you know let's figure out what to do Oh
the year before there was a pride parade
in San Francisco and some special you
know private people had made little
flags of their own but they weren't
rainbow flags they're like a purple
triangle and some other a friend of mine
has a photograph of the year before
there's just like a couple of little
things that people would hold in their
hands as they walked you know our
homemade banner downstairs on the second
floor is where the parade committee was
working like doing like this where the
stage where's the route where is the
permits where is the porta-potties all
the practical stuff does she need if
you're gonna put on a parade they were
busy with that you know it was the place
was jamming I think we had about six
weeks to get it together once we decided
on this and got all the materials all
the fabrics 1,000 yards of white cotton
muslin and the dyes salt so - the trash
cans that all the things and that we
brought our sewing machines we had 3
sewing machines three ironing boards
three irons and all the little stuff the
main three people were James Gilbert and
I but I found that once I started the
dyeing I was so busy dying I didn't have
time for sewing so someone just used my
sewing machine so it's not like cut and
dried
Oh meeting it - I didn't even have a
telephone you know you can find me here
my studio was on the second floor and we
started in there we were making such a
mess and there's no drains in the floor
there so Lee said why don't we do it on
the roof because there's a chip on the
top of the roof of the gay community
center there's this water main for the
firemen it just pours out cold water and
there's these giant drains in the roof
so we brought our trash cans up there
and then we that was off the third floor
you had to go up this staircase that was
really like a giant ladder so we heated
water up in giant canning pots on the
second floor carried him up to the third
floor then carried him up to the roof
dumped it in the trash cans along with
cold water mixed it and then the daya
salt and soda ash and
and mix to mix and then the fabric and
so that's where helpers not only were
they downstairs ironing fabric after it
been dyed and washed everything had to
be ironed and helping the seamstresses
tailors and then mostly it was Glen she
was working with me at the dye trashcans
I was the first person that was running
the stuff to the wash mat laundromat
with coiours and big giant garbage bags
to wash it then they're like oh you're
wasting time we need you upstairs so
here we'll get these people to do that
it was all figuring out how many yards
of this because the the two large ones
were forty feet by sixty feet on 80-foot
flag poles just very big they were large
and when they were finished it took
about three people to carry one flag the
two flags had eight colors yeah it was
pink red orange yellow green aqua blue
royal blue and violet and then mine had
stars in the corner for to emulate the
American flag and I reversed the colors
on the two flags this is on purpose it
so if you look carefully at the any
photos from that day
pink is at the bottom on one flag and
violet at the top and the other flag has
it reversed
we had to rig the flags get the person
with a key to the flag pulls the crank
to the flag poles and the trot her truck
and six of us or eight of us get them
over there and then clip them and take
the wire rigging that goes through the
end of the flag and it's clipped on both
ends and then you know put it up and
then crank crank crank and get it to go
up to the top and do the other one the
same thing bring it
and then crank crank crank and see if
they came out okay that was a I think
the day before so then we took it all
down we went back to the gay community
center obviously we were up early and we
got up the flags back in the truck and
all went over there and because we'd
have to get those up before the parade
started obviously and it's a big job and
so they went up and it looked great
I wanted a full spectrum rainbow I
wanted all the colors and for me it
meant everybody is included everybody
it's not like oh the color of skin no
everybody likes rainbows we're at the
gay community center and there's
everybody is there I mean you don't have
to be gay to be there but you know if
you are it's great and you know like
come on over and then we had to get
arranged we walked in the parade and so
in Gilbert and James and I and I guess
probably all of us and it was a great
day then within a year from 1978 gay
freedom day to the next year the flags
were stolen the two giant flags and that
was just like I was just such a shock
that I couldn't believe it that was just
our heartbreaker the gay community
center got torn down and made into a
parking lot
AIDS epidemic was happening people are
strung out on heavy drugs and a lot of
other bad stuff and it was just like
dark really dark it was a very sad time
we all left because there was no place
to be and I think it took it took years
before there was another gay community
center in San Francisco and now I
continue to dye fabrics for a living but
Gilbert he wanted to you know keep
putting the flags up and promoting and
so the next year he got together
polyester flags they made polyester
flags he's the person that promoted it
and popularized it and promoted it and
pounding the pavement and brought out
the flags for all sorts of events and
there was no Stars and Stripes when
she doesn't know how to do that so I'm
really glad it came to be a big huge
symbol and Gilbert's directly
responsible for doing that but I always
felt like he should give James and I do
credit you know whenever I see a rainbow
flag it makes me feel good you know I
was directly involved and with creating
that even though the original flags were
stolen and then they were modified it
still means the same thing we're all
included everybody no matter who you are
what you are doesn't really matter and I
think a rainbow it's a symbol of joy
beauty color light that's what it means
to me when I see rainbow flags hanging
in the window or flying I'm like ah yeah
there's my flag
[Music]